hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we were actually just
preparing to do a live stream and then
John I caught the notification that the
Annabelle comes home trailer officially
dropped here on YouTube did not see that
coming hey before we go into this I
wanted to say thank you to a couple of
things one John and I were in the
free-for-all for the Schmo down I want
to say thank you to all the random
tweets and comments I've been getting
about my specific appearance there would
love for you guys to go check that out
beyond my little moment it's just an
amazing amazing event they put together
at the Schmo down oh yeah just yesterday
I was in Anaheim at the and I'm
Convention Center for WonderCon and
screen junkies let me be a part of their
screen junkies panel cuz a person who
you guys will follow this channel know I
was such a huge fan of screen junkies
movie fight show to screen junkies in
general to think that I'm gonna freakin
WonderCon panel simulator does it
hitting me so hard a like I can't
believe I'm up here with that means it's
arrived been pretty cool and you know
wanted to cap off the week with a
livestream take tomorrow off but hey
Emma hook comes home that just footage
from the conjuring oh yeah I'm liking
this I'm liking the concept a lot yeah
okay
who's that in the corner go storm
Joaquin Phoenix
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
yeah yeah I've seen this scare and I've
lured this franchise you
[Applause]
ever improving upon the gym scare I
suppose that jump-scare we've seen in
was like the first contrary movie with
the pulling and then the bed was from
the did the grudge or some yeah I feel
like yeah that sounds about right
this is I have a weird response to this
trailer because I don't I mean I've seen
all the conjuring universe films and I
by the way go check out her nuns
catacomb video that we did that was a
great experience thank you again Warner
Brothers for bringing us out there for
that that was crazy yeah i i'd literally
i don't know if anyone really knows much
about this one but i knew nothing about
what this is gonna be I thought Annabel
creation was a was a really great
improvement upon the first Annabelle
film and it sounds like what are they
gonna do here but if with the flower I'm
conflicted is what there's one side of
me on the more on the negative side
that's like yeah this doesn't look like
anything really all that special or
different and it looks pretty generic
white young girls in trouble but but the
thing that got me excited was oh they're
actually the ruler throwing the war in
here and this is a calm place indirectly
yeah they're puts directly into where
like in some ways this is the conjuring
- yeah ring directly yeah yeah yeah like
having the Warrens being there's very
exciting element to me and and the
timeframe in which this is taking place
I think is a very neat and very cool
idea it's just the first trailer itself
in terms of like scares I'm like I feel
like we've seen these scares well
there's a lot of this is repeating other
things Annabelle's already done well in
this kind of movie right now is just
really really popular and it's you know
jump scares are being invented and
reinvented right constantly and so I do
one
how much longer we can persist with this
because you know the supernatural is
like you know our current zombie mode
it's like yeah we've done this a whole
lot now yeah yeah well I'm also thinking
like depending on how this ends if this
is a I guess in terms of conjuring
universe like universe building wise
this gets me pretty intrigued I'm
definitely very intrigued by it because
I'm thinking okay if if this is is this
like the final Annabelle movie is it
gonna end in a way where like we see
okay we've closed the book on the
Annabelle story or is this somehow going
to affect whatever the conjuring three
is going to be you know will it bleed
into that in some way and they really
start doing a universe building element
because especially now because before
they're like a spin-offs prequels you
know with the Warrens are kind of
referenced but now they're actually huge
you know yeah yeah I'm fascinated by
this trailer in a sense because it
almost feels like two trailers fused
into one because part of it looks like
you're kind of run-of-the-mill like you
said like young women finding the dog
getting terrorized and yeah feel like
that the guy who directed as if James
wonder if note that I think this guy is
written most of the conjuring universe
movies or hasn't written a lot of them
and now is stepping into the directors
role and yeah Gary Doberman awesome
which you know I mean there have been
better and worse conjuring installments
so you know I'm relatively open to what
his take is but this is the Simon
Kinberg edition yeah and so the thing
about the trailer is that half of it
looks kind of like a movie I've seen a
million times and the other half is like
oh it's like a warren movie but at least
as this plays as a trailer they don't
really feel like they're all part of one
coalesced worry to me and somewhat the
pretty I get what you're saying on that
and feel disjointed somehow to me well
I'm I'm curious I'm funny enough is this
like as much as sometimes I can get
annoyed by other franchises and other
studios doing universe building this is
the first time within the conjuring
universe advertisement or
I actually got very excited by the
universe building idea yeah yeah it's
the first time that's really happened
for me here dude Tony Stark's in this
one so in that way I think that the
trailer is a great success and that in
that capacity but the thing is I'm also
likeable the most exciting part to me is
like the wardens around here you know
yeah yeah and I wonder how much this
trailer resembles the proportions of the
movie because they're not all over this
trailer they're like at the beginning
and end of it sure so I'm guessing I'm
more curious to see what it does for the
universe more than I am for the actual
film itself although I am intrigued by
the idea that this guy is jumping from
writing some he has a pretty big
filmography on writing and now he's
hopping into the directing territory
afford this movie that that gets me
excited another thing that also gets me
very intrigued by it is the production
design of some of the ghost elements are
very insidious reminiscent yeah
like I know that you know with the James
one the people he works with and stuff
he offers sometimes I kind of bleed
together in imagery but the imagery
here's looked very specifically very
much like an insidious villain yeah and
the ghosts in the fog but yeah and I
think it's got something to do with the
colors too because it's a little more
garish in certain moments and yeah
they're I do get a certain odd
insidiousness about it and the idea to
that and the daughter of the Warrens has
always has been a factor into like scary
moments that happen in the construction
conjuring - yeah so to have her be more
of a main character than the warns
ourselves I think is a neat idea I think
there's a lot of really cool concepts
here a lot of cool ideas and I think
that there's a lot that could actually
make this really worthwhile and as the
trailer feels reminiscent of the other
Annabelle trailers but I think Annabelle
creation and the first Annabelle are
very different and I feel like
ultimately this will probably be a
little bit different than what Annabelle
creation was - I hope so I mean I like
that they're still keeping it in period
to a degree
yeah it's not I feel like at the time at
which we got Annabelle creation and we
do
origin of evil you know there was a
certain trend of like let's go like
really period peace rise and this seems
like it's kind of splitting the
difference and again you have that added
benefit of putting it into the familiar
world of the Warrens and all that stuff
yeah and yeah you know like I I'm
excited for some of the set pieces and
for the vibe of it I don't really hope
that especially on the heels of
Annabelle creation that they can deliver
something that you know is still
inventive and is still you know engaging
I'm sorry I don't remember if she using
the other ones but um the the little
girl who plays Theo young Theo on the
haunting of Hill House is in this
trailer is terrific on that show so I'm
excited to see her in this not that I
guess it'll be a stretch for her cuz you
know it's another ghost shouter sure but
yeah I'm intrigued yeah well before we
wrap this up I would like to give a
patron the day shout out to a very
special woman named Jenna Randolph
because recently she actually sprained
her arm she was looking something very
heavy at work and she hurt herself and
as you're recovering Jenna I would tell
you this right now in the most in
serious way don't go to the hospital
whatever hospital bill money you were
gonna use for health insurance or an
emergency room visit just use that
income and use it to increase your
patreon pledge
that's what will really heal your arm
doing good for people who are doing fine
right now pay it forward that's what you
gotta do my dear yeah on a serious note
double it you're you're amazing you're
beautiful woman and we love the hell out
of you my dear
much love alright guys you excited for
Annabelle comes home yeah subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and go ahead and check
us on patreon we got plenty of goodies